[Music]
well thank you
so much wade that was really great and
i'm happy to
to invite you on for some q a welcome
wade davis thanks sander
um we're we're pre-recording some of
this q a because you
you might be heading off on uh on
another expedition is that right
yeah i just don't know where i'm going
to be on june 29th you know i mean we've
been
um kind of a hell in canada we've been
very restricted
uh i haven't left this little island
virtually uh
except to go skiing a few times since
the covid thing struck
this talk is really important to me
because i i actually um you know my
mother was an
anthropologist and um and i got into
design kind of as in a way as
as a way of kind of doing anthropology
and and um and
what was very frustrating to me is i
went i went to a university so i could
take university classes along with
design classes
and then when i took anthropology it was
all about self-reflection of the field
rather than
the work and so and so i basically just
didn't do it and it was very frustrating
and so this is
this really resonates with me and i'm
i'm wondering is there a generation of
either explorers or storytellers or
or even anthropologists grad students
that are willing to go to the field or
are you seeing that's just trying oh
absolutely but they
but but they're you know in many cases
their work is not being supported by the
by the funding agencies that are
controlled by this orthodoxy
um uh you know there's never been
more uh a stronger cadre of imaginative
explorers than the millennial generation
i mean
you know part of this for me is that
when i uh
you know turned my back on academic life
it didn't mean
i stopped being an academic every one of
my books i've written 23
is a phd for my book on everest i bought
600 books visited 57 archives
you know made three field expeditions to
the flanks of everest and and spent
months in monasteries the point is
you continue to do the ethnographic work
it's just that you publish
in outlets that
that are accessible to people and
meaningful to people
look we live we live in a time where
according to a study of derek
bach fully 98
of academic papers in the humanities and
75 percent in the social sciences
are never cited again never cited once
well that's a measure of their relevance
um
you know we we we live in a world
where at a major university like
university of british columbia where i'm
on the faculty uh something on the order
of 70
of our successful phds do not get
academic jobs
and yet the pedagogy is still based on a
calcified 1960s model
that said that if you got a phd you
became a professor and so what have we
done
the number of phds being produced is
soaring the number of tenured positions
is dropping
and the number of sessional employees uh
in some cases poor men and women living
in the backs of cars
you know being paid pittances to do
coursework for
uh classes full of students whose
parents are paying huge amounts of money
and tuition
uh to support that university we watch
at universities where the
the the percentage of the budget
committed to administration
is soaring whereas that pedagogy and
teaching
is declining you see that these
universities are frankly
working their way out of relevance and i
mean you touched on this a little bit as
the you know
this this massive wild kind of human
experiment that we're in the middle of
right now
covet and i'd love to just get you you
talked in your essay but
you know what is anthropology where does
it fit into
an amazing kind of time that we are in
amazing in the sense it's kind of
horrible but amazing
never in history has the entire world
focused on the same problem you know a
pathogen 10 000 times
smaller than a grain of salt which not
only commandeer our biology
but attack the network of community and
con
connectivity that is for a a social
species what teeth and
claws represent to the tiger you know we
we saw the world shut down
and but also in that vision we saw what
the world is i mean one of the
extraordinary things about kovit is that
we saw the resilience of the earth
you know overnight the skies clearing
over kathmandu and delhi and mumbai
for the first time in a generation wild
boar in the streets
of of of barcelona
wools and grizzlies in the floor of
yosemite the canals of
venice clear rivers in colombia running
like brook streams
you know it it i found that really
inspiring and
humbling and also it showed the impact
of
human activities on the earth of course
but you know it's it's humbling to
remember um
xander if you took the entire hominid
presence on earth i don't just mean
homo sapiens and going back to our
immediate progenitor homo erectus but
all the way back to
homo reforensis which is somewhere 2.3
million years ago
and you take that entire timeline and
put it on a 24-hour clock of the history
of the earth
the entire hominid presence would not
occupy a second
so in other words you know the weed will
win in
the end as that great sierra club book
said the question is
will we leave to our descendants in
earth that we can be proud of
and i think kovid you know many things
will change
coming out of kovid i think we've
discovered
that that people can work in a digital
age at home not all peoples and
certainly
not people who have to scramble for a
living every day on the streets of
cities like medellin and
lima and mumbai but certainly a number
of us can
and i think we can look back also um at
the frenet
frenetic travel schedules that we all
once had as a kind of
violent hallucination uh i never want to
have to travel like that again
it doesn't mean i won't travel for
purpose and for for
for for meaningful experiences and i
hope we all do more of that
but that image we all have of chicago's
o'hare airport on monday afternoon
like ants in a ant nest right you know
i think some of that's got to i mean
what manager can rationalize the expense
of
flying in the executive team to san
francisco putting them up in the w
hotel and all that kind of racket you
know so i think i think i think
or people getting flown around the world
for a 45 minute time oh that's right
that's what i used to do i'd fly off to
cleveland to the ball bearing
manufacturers associated
and now of course i mean i i've found
that this new world of zoom
is has been so liberating for me now i
don't want to under
in any way under um state the the the
sadness and the misery we feel for those
who have suffered not
just who have lost loved ones but the
economic dislocations i mean i
i'm lucky enough to be in a place where
i didn't have economic pressures i i
i live in a place that's beautiful and
bucolic and it was a pleasant place to
sit out the pandemic so i
i'm not trying to um say that that i
wasn't
very much a person of privilege in that
um but
at the same time i remember i woke up
one morning
and uh i edited in with that that
rolling stone piece edited another piece
i was doing for a publisher in
toronto uh uh participate in the sonoma
writers festival
a wonderful festival that i didn't have
to go to i could just
you know and i had 4 000 people instead
of 400 people
then i administered an exam to a kid in
singapore got it back
graded it put into the registrar at the
university looked at my watch zander it
was 11 o'clock
and i went out and planted a fruit
orchard you know i mean like
i think i think we can find ways to
i hope i hope we'll learn from um our
our
our year of of quietude and i want to
come back to this thing that you
mentioned in the
in your talk this kind of nexus of where
um
where you know cultural and linguistic
loss is often a precursor to massive
environmental loss and
and i think you know there's this as you
were mentioning as we lose language
after language
um and we lose the work the indigenous
people lose the words
for the things around them that also
seems to
presage them losing the care for a lot
of the things around them and moving
away from their
their their you know ancestral areas
um and so i think this is a you know
it's rare that you have a signal where
you can get a 20
year head start knowing that the
environmental loss is going to happen in
a place that's one of the kind of
signals that we
that that this kind of information gives
us but we don't seem to be acting on it
in a very good way
people are recognizing that much of the
at least terrestrial
uh extent biodiversity pristine lands is
at least titularly under the control of
indigenous people and so for example my
my good friend pete seligman who created
conservation international
now is with the support of the emerson
collective he's got a new organization
neotero
which is trying to work directly with
indigenous people to
um as colleagues to empower them uh to
be
stronger and more forceful and more uh
empowered advocates of their own
homelands and that
that kind of combination of uh a
environmental vision of which pete
personifies
uh particularly in the tropics with the
the the support for indigenous people
was almost unimaginable
in the year for example when pete um and
russ mittermeier and
and you know others came together to
create ci
so i think that's all very positive and
you know again indigenous people uh
uh you know what it's a little bit like
the environment you know i think we're
impatient with the pace of social change
but you know
when i was a kid just getting people to
stop throwing garbage out of a car
window was an environmental victory
nobody spoke about the biosphere
now that term is part of the vernacular
of school children and by the same token
when i first went to colombia in 1974
for example and i'd say to my
my friends the parents and my friends in
particular at the the nationale
the university that i was going to live
with the arawakos
in the seattle nevada they would say to
me you know porque quiere de via con
lenti socio why do you want to live with
the dirty people well
there have now been five colombian
presidents whose first
act of office even before their
inauguration has been to go
to the sierra to pay homage to the mamos
who have emerged kind of of symbols of
continuity and
and hope in a country that's been torn
by the drug wars
uh so so you know
it's there's much progress to be made
but we've come
in a sense a very long way and it's an
ongoing again as i said earlier
there's not a clear victory line or an
ending line it's just a process we have
to continue to do
the idea that nations in canada treat
nation to nation with the federal
government
would have been unimaginable in the
lifetime of my grandfather
but now it's something that not as only
not only occurs
it's broadly supported by by the
canadian people
and we're proud of it well and what
we're going to wrap up here a little bit
i just wanted to
um get a sense of you know what's what
is next for you as the
as the pandemic lifts um do you i know
your your most recent book
was uh just out uh this fall about uh
river and columbia and what's your
what's your next project well my
my my real devotion is to colombia where
i was made an honorary
citizen by the nobel laureate juan
manuel santos who's become a good friend
you know the book i wrote magdalena
river of dreams is really
an attempt to write a biography of a
country through the metaphor of its
its mississippi if you will the
magdalena the river of life the river
that made possible the country
colombia is a gift of the river and um
the book was conceived in a moment of
great optimism in a sense written over
five years
sparked in part i was there during the
the uh historic signing of the peace
agreement
and it's be and because of the success
of other books that i've had my the book
el rio for example
which was published in colombia in
2002 a low point in the country's
fortunes
and it became not just a hit book but
kind of a map of dreams for generations
of kids who couldn't travel within their
own their own country and it was
embraced by
all sides of the colombian spectrum old
and young
left and right and it was actually named
by the biblioteca nationale
as one of the first 25 of what will be
the
top 200 books in the history of the
country which was a singular kind of
honor and because of that book and
films i've done positions i've had
speeches i've given the new book
i have a a a voice in columbia that is
is something that i have to use
effectively and and humbly
and now my question is how to use it in
the wake of these the recent
disturbances that
have wracked the country it's a it's a
it's a very sad situation that
i think the world needs to understand i
mean let's just remember that 260
thousand dead
a hundred thousand missing seven million
internally displaced five million
force to flee how would the united
states feel if canada
had patterns of drug consumption laws
that
did nothing to limit the trade but uh
but empowered the cartels such as 85
million
americans would be forced from their
homes well that's what happened in
colombia and yet during all those
terrible years
of a war that not would not have lasted
a day without the cocaine money
uh last year of war incidentally the
farc made 600 million dollars
from kidnapping extortion and drug
trafficking give me the
boy scouts of san francisco of marin
county and 600 million dollars i can
create havoc in northern california uh
and
and uh um during all those years
columbia maintained civil society
democracy greened at cities
uh sought restitution with indigenous
people as i've mentioned
created millions of acres of national
parks and paved the way
for a cultural economic renaissance as
two generations of kids
forced to flee are coming home with
skill sets and everywhere but here's
where things went wrong santos
negotiated the peace agreement
the peace agreement had clauses that
would cost 45 billion dollars mostly
about social development
infrastructure development then into
office
came duque a protege of alvaro uribe
who ran against the agreement and if he
didn't actively dismantle it he
certainly did little to
implement it and he didn't have the
gravitas himself that as santos who just
electrified the world by winning the
peace prize
would have had say he had had a few
extra years in office
and because of that into the void
created by the
retreat of the farc and the failure of
the federal state to enter
entered into that area dissidents
cartels remember we've continued you
know until we do the cleansing stroke of
legalization cocaine
will be the curse of colombia the rivers
of blood will still flow because of
cocaine
and then and then on top of everything
faced with the expenses of
implementing the accord the price of oil
collapsed
colombia's main source of foreign
revenue and then colombia did something
that hasn't gotten credit for it
uh the biggest humanitarian crisis in
the history of the americas
had two million venezuelans come into
colombia and they weren't rejected at
the border as america rejects people
from central
america they were welcomed housed fed
schooled given health care and given
permission to work
and then comes kovit the economic
collapse
the social collapse poverty rates
increase
after having gone down for years and
there and then comes together a kind of
a perfect storm
uh you know an ill-conceived uh
tax proposed that's gonna that people
just want to hear about
in their time of economic need and
misery
uh various um uh students
students with their grievances
indigenous people with their grievances
you know and again it's like black lives
matter it explodes for
uh in the streets it doesn't necessarily
mean that america
should be measured exclusively by what
happened in the summer of black lives
matter
for all that we need to recall and
acknowledge that wonderful phrase
um but but but so what's happening now
is sort of
this perfect storm and then it's been
accentuated by some police brutality
and um 40 or 50 at least people have
been shot unnecessarily mostly young
kids and again
what we forget is that the police part
of the department of defense
they're all coming out of a 50-year
conflict where escobar
in the very beginning made murder and
death cheap
right so you know i'm not saying that
the police
should be uh should be forgiven on the
contrary
but but you know you're you're talking
about security forces that have been
living through
all their lives a world of violence of
a three-sided war uh that saw 260 000
people killed
all because of north american and
european consumption of cocaine i might
add
and so so it's just broken like a storm
uh and and and you know
it's not going to put colombia back to
where it was
peace will never disappear the people
are too hungry for it and there is a
middle way in colombia
uh and and that middle way is what i
represent
and it's a place that i want to speak
from and so my biggest effort in the
next months will be doing everything i
can
for colombia in the peace process well
thank you so much for this talk and
thank you so much for joining us and
um can't wait to hear how it goes in the
coming months in columbia i hope you're
able to get back soon
thanks very much sandra and i want to
thank you our audience with long now
we look forward to having you at our
future talks thank you
you